[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the fate of house Greyjoy
about the fates of Theon urine urine
supported by leaked photos official
teasers in the official trailer because
Granger had been in an open rebellion
against the Iron Throne since the war of
the five kings during which it sought
independence for the Iron Islands once
more however following the death of King
Balon Greyjoy and the election of his
brother urine as the new king of the
Iron Islands house Greyjoy was divided
between urine and his followers and
baylin's thriving children Yara and
Theon and their followers yaris faction
which had aligned with House Targaryen
was defeated by urine who has aligned
himself with House Lannister upon the
beginning of the any Targaryen invasion
of Westeros at the end of season seven
ER is still held captive by urine who is
sailing to Essos to bring the golden
company to King's Landing and Theo needs
on his mission to save his sister and
get her back even though some of you
might not have caught it the official
trailer showed this urine as well as
team Greyjoy we saw a glimpse of your
grades are along with Harry Strickland
the leader of the golden company in the
Great Hall of the red cape in King's
Landing
in-depth analysis also revealed two
different set of gradual fleets with
different crack and painting sales one
belonging to urine on which Yara and
urine are and the other fleet belonging
to Yaron which is Theon trying to catch
up to urine and save his sister there
are few subtle differences between yarn
fleet and urine sign fleet has great
residual is traditionally a golden
cracking on a black field essentially
our suite uses young graduate has his
own personal schedule in the books and
season seven of the TV show introduced a
simplified version in the books it's a
red eye with a black pupil which is
surmounted by a black crown being held
aloft by two black grouse this is a word
play on his nickname crows eye the
season seven of the TV show also
introduced a personal sigil for urine
but because he's not missing an eye in
the TV version and his never cold crowds
eyebrow element was removed and just
combined with regular great heraldry as
a result he runs personal schedule in
the TV versions a gold Kraken on a black
field with the third eye is scribed onto
the head
the Kraken so basically the only
official difference between Yaris and
euros fleets is that urines has a third
red dye inscribed under the head of the
Kraken
I also found one more difference and
it's in the fact that the shape of the
sails are different as well
yarr favor square iegs well you're an
outsider zone terrifying galley silence
prefer support ships that employ
triangle fore and aft breaking the
silence Iran's long ship returning to
Westeros alongside the rest of your
elite in the background loaded at the
division of the golden company in their
commander Harry Strickland the trailer
also provided one more shot oh great a
fleet and since it contains square rigs
type of sales and more importantly since
there is no red dye on the Kraken we can
tell for a fact that its Yaris fleet
commanded by Theon Greyjoy in the season
7 finale film finally gained respect of
the Ironborn and rarely the artists
remaining supporters to rescue Gaara and
here they are in season 8 searching for
urine slate many fans were worried that
the era might actually get killed early
on in season due to her absence from the
official poster since season 8 promotion
photos an anxious to play Sierra debunk
these rumors by tweeting out this to her
fans your kind to worry but fear not
having a baby and filming schedule
clashes meant I could not make the
photoshoots
she'd event on to confirm her appearance
in the final season airing I'm guided
not to be on them can't wait for you to
see the final season I can't wait to see
it
theanine Yara will reunite early on in
season we know detect herself Helen and
Jim of Eleanor filming on the set in
Bainbridge where a group of actors
playing Ironborn soldiers Pylos Bay who
plays urine was nowhere to be seen in my
opinion Theon will be saving Yarra
Valley receiving a meeting with Circe
and Harry the thing I'm most curious
about is Didier maybe do something to ER
in the meantime and what we know that
urine loves to rip the tongues to his
crew and his prisoners all the same
urine is the captain of the ship silence
screwed entirely by mutes to keep them
revealing from any of his secrets your
own personal rip the tongues out of each
of their months in the books urine does
the same thing to several captured holy
man of fighter religions like the faith
of the seven hundred priests he has them
tortured with their tongues or other
body parts ripped out your notes orders
to Ty's younger brother
and his salt by failure to the prow of
the silence prior to the battle with the
red wine fleet failures shown to be
naked and never realizes that urine has
ripped out her tongue here on storage
methods in the books seem to be the same
on the show as well bill they are a
looser tongue or will film finer naked
tied to the prowl the silence are just
some of the possibilities however I do
believe that feeling will Savior and get
her back and the two will then say Lord
to help Jon Snow and Danny defend
Beneful the leaked photos already proved
that egregious will be part of this epic
battle against the night king with his
up-close shots of greater lifeless
bodies being on Winterfell sad during
the filming of that battle so we know
theanine Yara will reunite and they will
most likely then go to Manor fell and
helped the Starks and Targaryen is
defended as for urine he'll arrive at
King's Landing with the golden company
in the season 8 premiere
he'll then have a meeting with Cersei
and he'll probably demand a vetting as
it's been confirmed by the official
teases you know blackmailed serfs into
getting what he wants a marriage and he
will therefore become the king here's
the shot of Cersei Lannister Emma Lena
Headey who plays Cersei has to say is
more than interesting Lena says as usual
it Circe says she's trapped in a web of
her own making
what's nature of this wet Lena Headey
did not give any details of course but
looking on yours photo and what he's got
to say about his season 8 paths
it's more than obvious that Lena is
talking about Cersei getting trapped in
yours hands after she so foolishly let
her and make a contract with the gallant
company and making him so powerful over
all pile of a cure instead this urine
wants to become the king of the Seven
Kingdoms yet he is also blackmailing
Cersei here in his blackmailing Cersei
with the golden company and his own
fleet Cersei's got to marry earn or he
believed it his fleet and turn the
garland company against her as it might
be Cersei who paid them but it's yon who
made the deal with them and it's earned
whose name is on the contract
that's why Cersei trapped in a verb of
her own making and that's kuvira is
blackmailing her regarding the endgame
of the Greyjoy's I definitely expect for
urine to be killed by the hand of Cersei
Lannister after she has done with him
and after she is used in although he
will use her as well without a doubt and
will probably be once again made to root
for Cersei just like we were rooting for
her against the High Septon urine will
blackmail her into doing so many things
for him and
him but at the end when she no longer
needs him sir civil killing triggering
theanine Yara I definitely do not see
both of them surviving one will die and
one who live I'm pretty sure thean will
die by either saving Yara or one of the
stalks
film-school story thus far is going on a
road to redemption film has finally come
to terms of growing up with both stark
and greater traits he wants to save his
sister and evil the only Redemption DML
have yet to fulfill is for all the
crimes he's done again the Starks and by
doing that I think he will die or more
detail he'll sacrifice his life to save
one of the Starks wit Iranian Theodore
is the only greater left and she'll be
the first ever queen of the Iron Islands
does the mean house greasier will not
see more than a couple of decades in the
future does the me house graduate dies
with the own urine in Yara no because I
think Theon might have a secret air in
the second episode of the second season
aboard the Mara ham a ship taking him to
Pike on Robb Stark's orders still paid a
visit to the captain's cabin which he's
taken for his own dairy meat the
captain's daughter who waits him in his
bed naked after a bit of small talk she
helps the enthroned lays his breeches
and tells him that he'll be a king one
day having an intercourse with her which
keep in mind is his last he's ever had
or he will ever have
most probably resulted with the
captain's daughter being pregnant with
his child in that very same thing Ian's
also happens to explain her the Ironborn
tradition of taking salt wise more poor
she begged him to take her as one she'll
bring born to salt Weiser not consider
bastards but they do rank behind
children of a lords rock wife an iron
Manchu spouse in the line of succession
which in this case is not important
since the EON is no longer capable of
producing a child in A Song of Ice and
Fire a series of epic fantasy novels on
which game entrance is based
there's even more clues that are leading
towards the conclusion that the
captain's daughter Shirley got pregnant
with Ian's child film tells her that her
father should be pleased Anat angry
since there's a high possibility she's
with a child and it's not every man who
has the honor of raising a king's
bastard perhaps this was a bit too
obvious for shadow and Claude to be
included in the show later in the books
it's also be highlighted how Theon is
confident that he got captain's daughter
pregnant there's one more cool that goes
in favor to this theory of mine and it's
from George armoire another book the
world of Ice and Fire
the untold history of Westeros in the
game turns in that both Willard Ethel's
rager had to be continued at least once
result Sons of salt wise as they're
threatened the Delton Greyjoy also known
as the red Kraken had never taken a rock
wife true spouse but had lots of salt
wives and therefore his closest heirs
were his salt sons if we stop for a
moment to think about it this could be
one of many for sheriffs includes the
theone actually has a salt son and there
that will be introduced in the show once
Jun is defeated steam kill Danny are
crowned house great she will not go
extinct but will rather continue through
the insult son otherwise I would not see
the point of all those clothes in both
the books in the show regarding the
captain's daughter's pregnancy there
would not either be a point in Georgia
Marsten reduction with different
approach to marriage inheritance
surrounding the Ironborn if the history
will not repeat itself once again if
house Greyjoy will not be continuing
routine salt son in conclusion the
gracious will continue to play their
important role in the final season with
in successfully saving Yara from their
uncle yearn and they're helping the
stars defend Beneful urine on the other
hand will play a huge role in South by
bringing the gun company to Westeros
blackmailing Cersei marrying the Queen
and becoming what he always wanted to be
the king of the Seven Kingdoms the rent
games are still not certain but in my
opinion urine will get killed by thirst
after he is no longer needed Theon will
sacrifice his life by saving the Starks
Yara will end up the queen of the Iron
Islands and house Greyjoy will continue
to team sacred son please let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below what do you
think rage rest will do in season 8 in
which graduates do you think will
survive and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace